here's one here's one dear Kerry my
humble 20 donation for your continued
fights against the evils at the Arizona
and DC cartels wow
this is a 20 check this came from Sun
City West wow I mean I guys I could go
through this whole thing this these
letters
move me to tears I want to meet the
person donating to Cary lake at this
point in time what on Earth could be
going through your mind if anything
for you to at this point say hey you
know what I think I'm gonna send Carrie
Lake money I'm gonna send her money at
this point in time the only reason
Carrie lake is still doing this stuff
after seven months is because someone is
donating money to her